today on the Matt Walsh show another
police shooting has sparked protests
this happened over the weekend but while
the left Democrats and protesters put
all the blame on the police officer as
per usual I think we need to start
asking some questions about the personal
responsibility of the suspect in these
cases especially that's an especially
pertinent question in the latest
shooting that has caused all these
protests we'll talk about that also five
headlines including a black trans lives
matter protest over the weekend what was
the point of this protest is it actually
necessary we'll discuss all of that and
our daily cancellation and much more all
coming up on the show today we begin
with this though another round of riots
broke out in Atlanta
this time over the police shooting of a
man named Ray chard Brooks the media is
quick to tell us of course that Rashard
Brooks is a black man and the officer
shot him as a white man but Brooks's
race appears to be far less relevant in
this situation than his behavior police
were called to a local Wendy's on Friday
night after Brooks fell asleep behind
the wheel in a drive-thru line in the
drive-thru line at Wendy's officers
arrived they detected a strong scent of
alcohol also he wasn't really making
sense he didn't seem to know where he
was not to mention just the fact that he
passed out a drive-through lane all of
that pretty good indication that he's
you know drunk so they do a blood
alcohol test and he was over the legal
limit not a big surprise
so they attempted to make an arrest
Brooks resisted assaulted the officers
stole one of the cops tasers fired it at
them ran away then turned and pointed
the Taser at the police officers and it
was at that point when Brooks had done
literally everything in his power to to
escalate a non violence situation into a
violent situation it was at that point
that one of the officers shot and killed
him there is a plethora of video footage
of this incident and I'll play for you
here here's the there are you know
civilians that are in the driveway and
some of them are taking video of it but
here's the combined footage for
the officers body cam and the Wendy's
security camera think it gives us the
best view of everything that happened in
context so here it is take a look
follow mr. Brooks will you take a
brilliant breath test for me yes or no I
don't know one of a few Hey it's yes or
no it's completely up to you okay just
wait here while I Drive I mean what kind
of drinks did you I'm not sure if some
she orders she said top shelf or
whatever
top shelf one I'm not sure it was like I
said her birthday and you had about one
and a half drinks but you don't remember
what kind of drinks they went loafer all
right I really don't all right I think
you've had too much to drink to be
drivers put your hands upon your back
for me
okay now the media has as I said of
course made this into a racial incident
continually highlighting the fact that
Brooks was black the officer was white
protesters have taken to the streets the
Wendy's where this occurred was burned
to the ground apparently for the crime
of calling the police on a man passed
out in the drive-through lane it would
seem that the protesters would prefer if
a business I don't know it just wakes
the drunk man out of his stupor and
sends him driving along on his wife what
else are they supposed to do because it
would seem that calling the police is is
what you would do if you're concerned
about his safety and also the safety of
the public the officer who shot Brooks
was fired he may be charged with murder
the police chief has resigned and all
the familiar wheels are turning once
again BLM activists and leftists have
denounced the shooting mainly by
pretending that Brooks went from
sleeping in his car to dead on the
pavement with nothing in between they as
always omit the most crucial elements of
the story so there's been a lot of this
kind of thing just as an example here's
a guy apparently according to his
Twitter an award-winning journalist and
here's how this how here's how this
award-winning journalist described the
incident when arguing with me over
twitter is what he said he said he
wasn't driving talking about Brooks he
wasn't driving he was asleep in a
parking lot and a few minutes later he's
dead no rational sane person would ever
argue that death should happen when
you've been asleep in a parking lot only
a cold non empathy empathetic I think he
meant to say empathy said empathic a non
empathic white nationalist would ever
make that insane argument yeah he was
just asleep in his car and then he was
shot dead and that's true of course he
was sleeping and then a little bit later
on he was shot dead that is in fact the
correct order of events I I will give
you that
but it's kind of like saying you know of
a convicted bank robber that he was
walking into a bank one afternoon and
then next thing you know he's arrested
and sent to prison that's the correct
order events but you left out some very
important events in between that would
connect these two events on the end and
make it in and clarify it quite a bit so
if you've ever seen you know that the
famous that the Seinfeld episode the
yada yada they are they are yada yada
inge past the most important part in
this case the award-winning journalist
he is just yada yada the part where
Brooks assaulted and stole the Taser of
a police officer so with protesters
rioters the media Democrat politicians
like the mayor of Atlanta who has
already come out against these police
officers all trying to turn this into a
cold-blooded murder by two racist
assassins out killing black men for no
reason I think it's important for us to
talk about the actual reality of the
situation let's bring this back to
reality Ville okay which is where I
personally prefer to be that's where I
like to hang out and be particularly
when we're assessing situations like
this I think it's better to do it in
reality what's the actual reality well
we're gonna run through that in just a
second but I want to take a timeout here
first to give you a quick message about
this show as you know we rely in part on
our advertisers to keep the mic hot the
lights on one thing that's really
important for us is is that we know
who's listening that's how we make sure
that we're featuring advertisers that
you folks actually want to do business
with which is best for us best for you
too it makes it more it makes it it
makes it more worth your time to watch
so if you have just a few minutes to
spare it really appreciate if you
visited the pod survey com to fill out a
short survey about yourself once we have
enough data that helps us find
advertisers who want to hear from you
then we can you know find then we can
really target this more and give you the
information you need so visit the pod
survey com take just a few minutes you
have five minutes right you have five
minutes of your day that you can spend
on this I think you can if you don't it
will personally offend me okay it might
make me cry
and you don't want to do that to me
complete the survey to help my team
bring you advertisers who you want to
hear from speaking of one of those
advertise
you really want to hear from expressvpn
you know if you if you browse the web
without a VPN to protect your
information you're really taking a risk
and you know worse than that it's a risk
that you don't need to take I can say
with full confidence that expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
expressvpn doesn't log your data lots of
really cheap or free VPNs make money by
selling your data to ad companies that
are not going to do that expressvpn
developed a technology called trusted
server that makes it impossible for
their servers to log any of your info
and also their speed you know I've tried
lots of VPNs in the past many slowdown
your connection make your device
sluggish I've been using expressvpn for
a long time and my internet speeds are
always blazing fast so and and also your
so it's it's it's safe it's fast it's
everything you need and something else
that really sets expressvpn apart from
other VPNs
is that it's very easy to use which is
important for me if it's not easy to use
I can't use it
so that's why this works for me so
protect yourself with the VPN that I use
entrust use my link at expressvpn comm
slash walls today get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
expressed VPN dot-com slash walls visit
expressvpn dot-com slash Walsh to learn
more alright so let's get into the
actual reality of this race shark Brooks
situation and let's go through the
timeline of events Brooks is very drunk
and driving he's a danger to the public
he falls asleep in the drive-through
lane why are the cops called is it
because he's a black man in his car
no we're that were the Wendy's employees
being racist did they call the cops
because they saw a black man in the
drive-through I think we can assume that
that many black men and many other races
have gone through the drive-through at
Wendy's and never had the cops called on
them why was this particular individual
why did he end up with the cops called
um because he was he was sleeping in the
drive-thru line they've got a guy passed
out blocking the drive-through to do
anything but call the cops would be
extremely irresponsible and reckless
the cops come do they come because it's
a black man do they say to the
dispatcher
okay well we'll respond to this call but
only if it's a black guy if it's not
then we're not interested
no now admittedly I don't have that that
interaction I don't know what they said
to the dispatcher but I think we can
assume that that conversation did not
take place so they show up they talk to
the guy they're very polite you saw that
in the video they're very reasonable
he's obviously drunk they have him take
the breath breathalyzer
looks like he blows a it looked like
it's at a point 108 the legal limit is
0.08 so he is well over the limit what
do they do now well he was behind the
wheel of a vehicle key in the ignition
passed out drunk that's a crime he has
committed a crime can they be merciful
and let him off the hook and not enforce
the law first of all why should they
second in any case no they can't do that
they can't just leave and leave the
drunk man in the parking lot to drive
home no he goes and he hit someone else
kills them we're gonna partially blame
the cops for that as well we should so
they have no choice but to make an
arrest it is the most responsible thing
to do it's the safest thing for the sake
of the public and for his sake he's a
danger to himself that drunk and driving
a vehicle are they arresting him because
he's black no they're arrest again
because he's committing a crime that in
dangers the public and himself there
could be they're arresting him for the
same reason they arrest anybody else in
the exact same situation they have to
bring him in keep him locked up let him
sleep it off yeah they'll probably
charge him with something pretty
standard procedure
I mean cops do this thousands of times
across America every single night but
now Brooks rather than accepting the
consequences begins arrest resisting and
then assaulting the officers and then he
steals the weapon out of their hands and
then he uses it against them and then he
runs away then he turns and points and
and tries at least tries to shoot it the
officers did everything they could to
de-escalate this situation the entire
time they keep saying you're going to
get tased
warning him over and over again they'd
they tell him hands off the Taser
warning him over and over again stop
fighting stop resisting warning him over
and over again they they really don't
want this to turn fatal
that's pretty clear Brooks is going out
of his way doing everything he can
everything he can to escalate this
situation even culminating in that
gratuitously stupid and pointless
decision to turn and point a weapon at
the officers as he's running away and
that was the last stupid decision that
Brooks made that night and it was the
one that cost him his life now we could
pick this apart we could Monday Morning
Quarterback it if we want we can come up
with the things that the cops could have
done differently sure we could now I
don't see anything they could have done
differently in in the lead-up to that to
that final moment up until that point
they are the picture of professionalism
and responsibility they're trying to do
everything they can to get this drunk
man off the street safely and
non-violently and so there's it's
totally by-the-book they're being very
patient but at the end of course one of
them takes his gun out of the holster
and shoots Brooks did he have to do that
did he have to probably not I mean in
hindsight but hindsight is something
that we as people watching this from the
comfort of our couches are privileged to
have in the heat of them want talk about
privilege okay we've got privilege in
that we're not in this situation and
we're probably not ever gonna be in this
situation in the heat of the moment from
the officers perspective they have gone
suddenly from a relatively routine
situation arresting a drunk guy to a
struggle for their lives when you're
wrestling a man he's grabbing for your
weapon that's a struggle for your life
your life is now on the line he could
kill you and you have every reason to
think he wants to kill you and when he
runs away and point something at him you
know he's running away point something
at the officers do they know it's the
Taser could it be a gun that he had on
him the whole time they haven't had a
chance to search him yet
and what if he hits one of them with the
Taser and then and then circles back now
that they're incapacitated takes the gun
from them these are all calculations
that they have to make in a split-second
in an extremely charged situation and
not a situation they created or wanted a
situation that they were voiced into
that they were plunged into against
their will so the question is not
whether shooting Brooks makes sense to
you watching the footage three days
later while comfortably sipping your
coffee and say oh here's all the things
I could have done differently if it was
me this is what I would have done the
question is whether it could have
reasonably made sense to them from their
perspective in the thick of it and I
think the answer is yes but here's a
crazy idea okay I've got a really wild
thought what if for once for a change
just one time we talked about the
choices made by the suspect
okay the criminal this was a criminal
he's committing a crime a dangerous
crime where his choice is justified was
he behaving in a way that respects the
lives of the officers and those around
him and even himself I mean black lives
matter did he believe that did did he
believe behave like he thinks life
matters black lives matter his own life
matters what responsibility does he
carry for all of this you see every time
this kind of thing happens we talk about
what the cops did what they should have
done what they could have done we never
stopped to say what did the suspect do
what could he have done differently what
should he have done yet we hold up the
officers 100% responsible for everything
while holding the suspect responsible
for nothing as if he's an infant or
pre-programmed robot as if he himself is
not a grown adult man
making choices now just some more
examples of what people have been saying
to me you know about this stuff all
quite typical ted Lieu said taser is a
non-lethal weapon rashard was running
away killing him was unjustified and
excessive use of force that's why the
cop has already been fired to the police
chief resigned
now the cop has been fired two police
chief resigned out of sheer cowardice
and caving to the mob it's got nothing
to do with the reality of this situation
excessive use of force
didn't Brooks use excessive force when
he was at when he assaulted a police
officer who was just trying to enforce
the law in this case a very good law the
law against drunk driving what about his
excessive use of force I mean that was
kind of excessive wouldn't you say why
are we talking about that
Bakari sellers a CNN analyst said to me
DUI is not a death penalty crime they
shot him in the back running away is
enforcing our anti drunk driving laws a
death penalty crime I mean were the cops
committing some kind of crime that they
should been punished for by Rashard
Brooks he assaulted them and stole their
weapon did they deserve that yeah the
left is all about autonomy and agency
supposedly they even have an autonomous
zone now you have a whole zone for
autonomy well each individual person is
in a sense in their own little
autonomous zone in that you're a person
making choices so what about Brooks is
autonomy what about his agency he is an
agent acting in his own right he chose
to turn a non-lethal encounter into a
lethal encounter how much responsibility
does he bear for that zero I mean is
that what you're gonna tell me he has
zero responsibility I mean does he have
zero responsibility for how he acts no I
say a hundred percent he is a hundred
percent responsible for his own behavior
who else can be responding if he's not
responsible for than someone else's and
I don't know who that would be I'm not
you're not
the cops aren't someone someone is
deciding how Brooks acts and I say that
Brooks himself is deciding that I can't
think of who else could possibly be
besides him now think about this for a
second
the people who are saying that that the
cops should not have shot Brooks what
they're really saying is that Brooks
should have been able to assault police
officers steal their Taser and fired at
them without being killed so so I really
consider that position if that's if
that's your position it just meditate on
it for a second say it out loud say that
Ella I think a man should be able to
assault a cop steal his taser and fired
at him without being killed I think you
should be able to do that kind of thing
without getting shot by the cops how
much sense does that make
how insane do you feel making that same
you ought to feel pretty insane because
it is insane now it's also dangerous
what is that the kind of message we want
to send to criminals that you're that
you can do that and you're not gonna be
killed you you are you can do that
safely you you have the right to safely
assault a police officer and steal his
weapon out of his hands and use it
against him you should be able to do
that you can do that and you know you're
not gonna be killed for doing that
so go might as well give it a shot if
you're getting arrested give it a shot
hey why not assault a cop try to get
away I can't do anything is that is do
you really think that's a message we
should be sending to people it it's sad
that Brooks is dead it's sad that
anytime someone dies it's always sad but
it's sad because Brooks threw his own
life away for no reason
it is sad because he made the choices
that he made and brought this on himself
this was his fault he is responsible he
paid the price the ultimate price and
it's a sad price it is very sad but it's
the price that anyone is at risk of
paying if they make the choices that
this man made this is not a story of
police brutality it's a story of a man
named Rashard Brooks who did a bad thing
driving drunk and followed it up with an
enormous
stupid and reckless thing assaulting a
cop and stealing his taser and and and
after that night a night filled with bad
stupid reckless choices he died as so
many others have after nights like that
if you go out one night and decide to do
a bunch of bad stupid reckless things
you might die and that's why I really
hope you don't do that because it's sad
it's sad for someone to throw their life
away you know we've been told by the
media and by rate by Brooks's family and
the lawyers that you know he's a he's a
father just wanted to get home to his
kids
I believe he loved his kids he's a
father okay you want to get home to your
kids that's not how you act you want to
get home to your kids you don't drive
drunk you want to get home to your kids
you don't you don't assault a police
officer and steal his weapon and then
turn around and pointed at him you know
anytime I go out I always want to get
home to my kids
that's why I would never do those things
so you know we could get into the
psychology of it why did he act that way
part of it he was drunk yeah that's part
of it but that's nobody's fault but his
own and no one else can be responsible
for that he chose to get drunk and drive
so we can get into the you know what why
did he make these choices and so on and
so forth but what you can't escape is
number one these were his choices that
he made at number two these are choices
that could get anybody killed which is
why it's very sad when people make
choices like this but it is not a moral
outrage it's not a moral outrage because
no moral atrocity was committed these
cops were responding to a situation that
they were thrust into by this man
there's no there's not
protests here unless we're gonna protest
when let me let me correct that actually
there is old there's a lot to protest in
fact you know let's let's protest this
message that's being sent by Democrats
on the left and the media that violent
criminals are not responsible for their
own behavior and that they should be
able to do whatever they want and still
be safe let's protest that message
because it's a dangerous message and
it's a message that's getting people
killed you want to talk about the
psychology of race Shar Brooks did maybe
one of the things that we can't know
exactly what was going through his head
I mean I can't imagine what would go
through someone's head to make them act
that way but maybe one of the things
going through his head is he thought he
could get away with this because of
because of the cops are under the
microscope now there's a whole bunch of
people they're recording he knows it did
that go through his head I mean has he
been watching the news and seeing as
people have been able to burn down
buildings and riot and assault police
officers not even get arrested and let
alone shot did was it was he thinking
about that maybe that's that's that's a
not an outlandish theory whether he was
thinking about it or not this is a
thought that's being put into people's
heads and so you know that's something
worth protesting but in the end this
comes down to his own choices
and we will move on now to headlines
number one there was another March over
the weekend aside from the George Floyd
marches and the Rashard Brooks margin is
another march on top of all these
marches this was a black trans lives
matter March BT L M
so here's aerial footage of the black
trans lives matter March in New York a
ton of people there and a few brief
things to say about this number one
the justification for this March is that
supposedly there's an epidemic of
anti-trans hate crimes especially
against black trans people and so
although black trans people and trans
people in general are a tiny subset of
the population we need to have a huge
March for them to stand up against these
against these hate crimes the reality is
that and in this another one of those
realities that most people don't want to
say because they're afraid of what's
going to happen but this is the reality
and I want you to pay attention there is
no epidemic of anti-trans a crime this
is a fabrication this is an invention by
the left it is not true like everything
else they say these days it is not true
it doesn't exist there is no epidemic of
anti-trans a crime they are lying they
are making this up which is why when you
listen to what the media is saying
they'll often tell you I was just
reading a CNN article about the black
trans you know matter protest and they
had a line of paragraph in there where
they setting was like 14 they said so
far 14 black trans people have been
killed in 2020 so that's all they tell
you as if the very fact that a trans
person is murdered is itself proof that
it was a hate crime as if every single
trans person killed is a victim of a
hate crime like there's no other reason
ever why a trans person would end up
murdered this is nonsense of course
trans people are going to be murdered
just like people in every demographic
are murdered they're not immune from it
unfortunately we live in a we're mortal
human beings and we live in a society
where murder happens happens it's
happening more and more across the board
in many cities at least and it's so
empty you could do this with every
demographic I mean I could give you a
stat for I don't know how many bird
watchers are murdered every year I'm
sure there's a certain number that are
murdered every year does that prove that
there's a serial killer out there
killing bird watchers or there's an
epidemic of anti bird-watching hate
crime no it just proves that bird
watchers aren't immune from being
murdered which we already knew
Chad Felix screen did a piece about this
for the Federals you can go look at a
excellent piece excellent reporting and
and he looked at all the cases of trans
motors reported by the Human Rights
Campaign over the last several years and
he found you can go look at yourself I
mean you can go through the links and
look at which I have also done and he
found that the vast majority were
related to domestic disputes
prostitution or drugs not hate crimes
anti hate trans hate crimes are very
rare that's the fact do they happen sure
I'm sure they happen you know hate
crimes against all people haven't is
there an epidemic no it's a lie they are
making it up anyone who tells you
otherwise is is ignorant or lying second
point what about social distancing yeah
I mean this is the obvious way you look
at that picture there all these people
packed in in New York you know like the
epicenter of the what was the epicenter
of the pandemic and in America and and
that's happening so we're expanding the
exception we already know that you know
going to church I mean it's if you do
that you're gonna get coronavirus if you
go to like a restaurant you get
coronavirus you go to a beach you can
get coronavirus take your kids to the
playground
take send your kids to school they're
gonna get coronavirus but magically if
you're mad about a police shooting and
you go out then you're you're immune
from coronavirus and now we also have to
include if you're marching for trans
people you're also immune that confers
some sort of immunity over you
apparently which is a fact that even the
so-called public health experts seem to
be all but endorsing at least implicitly
endorsing okay number two important news
here the media reports that Nickelodeon
has confirmed that SpongeBob SquarePants
is gay in celebration of Pride Month
they've confirmed it but here's the
tweet that supposedly confirms this and
as you can see there they're celebrating
Pride Month and then we get you know we
see spun
Bob Squarepants and rainbow colors does
that mean he's gay well no because he's
a cartoon and he's also a sponge he's an
he's a non-existent sponge that's two
levels that would mean that he couldn't
possibly come out as gay sponges are
asexual by the way which means that
Sponge Bob Squarepants is in the lgbtq+
community a is in there somewhere I
think it's lgbtqia+ or something like
that and that a is asexual so sponges
are already in that community every time
you buy a sponge that in the detergent
in the detergent aisle at Walmart you
are showing your progress you're
supporting diversity those are different
kinds of sponges of course but anyway
why am I talking about this what a
stupid time we live in what has to pitch
stupid time number three here's a video
that's gone viral over the past day or
two I don't know who this woman is or
where she is but the location you know
doesn't really matter because this could
be any of the many neighborhoods
destroyed by rioting in recent weeks
here's a woman dealing with the
consequences of that rioting and some
very speaking of a sad video this is a
very sad video watch this
every grocery store looks like this
every girl she stole looks like this
everything it is either on the floor
look at this came to getting a fool for
my kids gee look at this came in the
store to try to buy some things I'm not
another thief
look at this I am so devastated right
now gee this is not okay for us to have
to live like this we just do fish like
this all the time and we saw black trial
we still black and Pratt that we ain't
gonna never be honest and be real about
what's really going on y'all are so
wrong for this you came in your
neighborhood it of yours I'm not a thief
I'm not coming in this store is stealing
nothing and there's nobody gonna turn me
into no animal but making me feel like a
thief y'all let the right folks since
y'all up once again yeah to all of you
tolerant liberals who displayed your
woke miss by justifying rioting while
sitting on your fat comfortable asses
insulated from the damage that's what
you supported right there that's on you
you know that's yours you you helped to
do that you cheered that on you gave
that cover you dress that up you
intellectualize that you rationalize
that and then you moved on feeling proud
of yourself feeling accomplished feeling
so sophisticated they you didn't have
the stupid simplistic view of rioting
that us peons have or we look at it and
just say well that's bad they have a
bunch of people tearing buildings down
and looting and burning buildings and
attacking people
I mean us dumb peasants right we look at
that and think that's just bad that's a
bad thing you shouldn't do that but you
up on your perch you were much smarter
than that I mean you you had the nuanced
perspective and realize that this is a
response to systemic discrimination and
did you know that was that was you're
very intelligent position and then but
then you go on and and feeling feeling
very good about yourself you move on to
the next thing
leaving that woman and many like her to
live in the rubble so congratulations
you despicable monsters you pee
of garbage garbage you you awful
miserable excuses or human beings
congratulations that's on you hope you
feel good about that number four here's
a leading activist on the BBC talking
about the Churchill statues that left us
one to tear down and apparently seeming
to reveal that she doesn't actually know
who Winston Churchill was watch this
should the statue of Churchill be there
or not do you think I haven't personally
met him but what I would rate is that
that question of whether he should
remain should be poor to the community
you haven't personally met him because
he's been dead for over half a century
so that's why that's why you have a
minimum this of course is very common
though this is this is what you expected
people ripping down statues they don't
know a damn thing about the people who's
whose statues these who are represented
in these days they don't know anything
about about them all they know is that
it's an old white guy and that's all
they need no more information needed you
think the people ripping down statues of
Columbus you think they could tell you a
single thing about Columbus other than
what they read in the Facebook memes
they could give you a whole list of
talking points it was a genocide all the
slaveholder rapists I mean they could
give you all that the stuff they read in
the memes they give you the meme
information the bullet points you think
they could speak coherently about
Columbus for like I don't know could
they give you a paragraph could they
write a six sentence paragraph about
Columbus anything about him no they
couldn't they they don't know anything
about him whatsoever they don't know
anything about any of these but this is
what happens when you have this is part
of what the school system has done aside
from radicalizing a whole generation of
Americans and making them hate their own
history making them hate their own
making them hate their own you know the
heroes of in America and of the West
Whiston Churchill and one of the
of the West this is something obviously
not just happening in the United States
but well it's one thing we get from the
school system the other thing is the
other crucial ingredient is absolute
ignorance of history
they've got anger and bigotry and
certain sort of vague prejudices that
they get from the school system when it
comes to history but as for an actual
understanding of these historical
periods and these people and what they
did what they accomplished good and bad
they don't have that but they can tear
down a statue that much they can do all
right we're gonna move on now to our
daily cancelation and before we do you
know there's so much going on this year
in the news of course it's one thing we
you know whether there's there's a
never-ending just array parade of news
events unfortunately many of them quite
bad but it's hard to sort through it all
and to know what to think about all of
it and to know what's what's really
going on not so much what the thing
because what to think is up to you but
to know what's really going on is very
difficult especially when you can't
trust that you're getting the real
information from the media and that's
why you got to become a daily water
member get a readers past today from
daily wire comm you get access to
exclusive op-eds from us as well as
guest writers in-depth analysis from our
daily wire reporters on top of our
regular breaking news coverage this
membership tier is already a bargain at
3 bucks a month if you're joined today
you get the first month for 99 cents I
mean it's hard to beat that you also get
access to our mobile app receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content as well as you can join
the community of daily wire members who
are actively commenting and discussing
our content with each other that's
mobile ad free access to all of our
daily wire news exclusive op-eds and
more on the mobile app all for the price
of $1 go to daily wire comm so I
subscribe and join today ok finally for
our daily cancelation we're gonna be
canceling aoc for what is this the
fourth time maybe fourth or fifth time
the only person who's been canceled more
than aoc is my wife so they're they're
neck-and-neck at this point many reasons
to choose from when it comes to
canceling aoc but here's here's the
latest from her
I think even the term white fragility is
kidding like really set a lot of people
off and saying what do you mean I'm
fragile you know like this is offensive
and and and so it's almost ironic that
the term is kind of self evocative in
that way Congress is I don't know I mean
it changed a bit but prior to this term
Congress is about 90% white and which
means there are a lot of blind spots I
have seen a lot from legislators and
experienced a lot and and it's really
really difficult to confront and to see
how some folks political comfort is
prioritized above other people's ability
to survive and to live yes okay so the
most fragile woman in America who finds
sexism and bigotry around every corner
is now accusing other people of being
fragile talk about projection as for the
term white fragility well if you want to
get a good perspective on that term just
put any other color any other race in
front of the word fragility and see how
it looks but any other race in front of
the term fragility and would anyone deny
that it's racist its bigoted of course
not the same of course goes for men and
women I mean you can attach a whole
bunch of different words to male or
masculine that you can't attach to
female or feminine male fragility toxic
masculinity all of that so Kay but
female fragility toxic femininity no no
you can't do that that's sexist that's
terribly sexist what can we cure you
know that would be terrible
so aoc you see she herself is very
strong very reasonable very mature above
it all
as long as you play by her rules if you
accept her double standards without
questioning if you dance to her tune
then that's fine as long as she can live
in a world where she can vomit her
bigotry all over everybody else and
never once hear any criticism from
anyone ever then she's truly a strong
and independent woman and an inspiration
to us all but the moment she encounters
any pushback the moment the moment she
gets the smallest dose of her own
medicine she breaks down in tears like a
damsel in distress has a temper tantrum
starts screaming about sexism and racism
it is it is somewhat similar to like a
three-year-old but a three-year-old is
you know it can be an angel very well
behaved as long as everything is going
their way you do everything a
three-year-old wants all the time never
give any pushback then they're gonna
behave great but the moment they
encounter some reality that will not
morph to their expectations
the moment you say something that alike
that's when they freak out and a OC is
very similar to that this is all a
tiresome game and we shouldn't play it
that's what needs to happen now just
don't play these games this double
standard stuff no it's not gonna work
that way I'm sorry one rule for everyone
that's it that's all you get you don't
get your own rules we're not gonna abide
by that many people have have chosen to
go along with that for way too long I
think we need to stop now
no white fragility no you can't sorry
you can't say that you can't say that
it's not gonna work that way so here's
how it is gonna work go see if you want
to retain the right to accuse white
people of racism should they use a term
like fragility to describe other races
than their own which I'm sure I'm quite
sure you would want to call a white
person races for doing that then that
means that you yourself you must accept
are a dumb bigot a dumb hateful racist
bigot for using that term to describe
races other than your own that
the rule that you would want to apply to
white people I'm quite sure it's the
rule I mean you you called white people
racist for far less than that so that's
the rule you apply the way that same
rule goes to you and that would be a
perfectly consistent position for you to
take you can say aoc you can say yes I'm
an awful bigot
I hate races other than my own
particularly this one race over here I
hate you guys and white people who
behave and speak like me are also awful
bigots just like me we're all awful
bigots together
that's a fine position I me it's not a
fine position it's a pretty pretty
pretty terrible position morally
speaking ethically but it's consistent
it's intellectually consistent and
logical but that's what it's gonna be
now you this thing where you get to get
to go around saying white fragility and
no one calls you racist for it no no
you're done AOC
is a disgusting dumb bigot that's what
she is and that is just a bigoted
statement but I think what you said you
called a whole race of people fragile
what kind of disgusting racism is that
and we just accept this we just accept
this from a from a from a congresswoman
you think Trump could get away with that
you think you can get away with fragile
in describing any race of people what
kind of reaction would there be to that
yet AOC says it oh yeah sure white
fragility not to mention I mean we
talked about the double standards here
we could spend all day dissecting the
double standards but hey what do you
really mean when you call calling men
fragile calling white white people
fragile
what do you really mean that what
they're emotional they get offended
since when is that a problem I thought
you're okay with that
since when is it especially when you
hear about male fragility which is the
other that's kind of like the cousin of
white fragility and if you're a white
male then yours then you're double
double fragile but then the inter
thing is with male fragility we're also
told all the time that men don't display
their emotions enough they keep it all
bottled up part of toxic masculinity is
that men don't want to display their
emotions because they're afraid of being
accused being feminine and yet we can be
told that a man is toxically masculine
and he and he has male fertility which
is it it's kind of one of the other
because if he's fragile emotionally that
means that he's what he's too
emotionally showing off his emotions too
much the thing is I actually agree that
it's a problem for a man to be fragile I
don't agree that all men are but some
men are they shouldn't be but you as a
woke leftist you're supposed to be all
about that you should be defending that
so that's a wonderful thing you're
expressing your emotions oh no no no but
that but that's what you would do again
if you were consistent and not a bigot
which is what you are and so you're
cancelled and we will leave it at that
thanks everybody for watching have a
great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]